what i have here in yellow is the graph
of y equals f of x then here in this
move color i've graphed y is equal to
the derivative of f is f prime of x and
then here in blue i've graphed y is
equal to the second derivative of our
function so this is the derivative of
this of the first derivative right over
there and we've already seen examples of
how can we identify minimum and maximum
points obviously if we have the graph in
front of us it's not hard for a human
brain to identify this as a local
maximum point we might the function
might take on higher values later on and
to identify this as a local minimum
point the function might take on lower
values later on but we saw even if we
don't have the graph in front of us if
we were able to take the derivative of
the function we might or even if we're
not able to take the derivative of the
function we might be able to identify
these points as minimum or maximum the
way that we did it we said okay what are
the critical points for this function
well critical points are where the
function where the function's derivative
is either undefined or zero this is the
function's derivative it is zero here
and here so we would call those critical
points it's i don't see any undefined
any points at which the derivative is
undefined just yet so we would call here
and here
critical points so these are candidate
minimum these are candidate points at
which our function might take on a
minimum or a maximum value and the way
that we figured out whether it was a
minimum or maximum value is to look at
the behavior of the derivative around
that point and over here we saw the
derivative is dec or the derivative is
positive the derivative is positive as
we approach that point the derivative is
positive as we approach that point and
then it becomes negative it goes from
being positive to negative as we cross
that point which means that the function
was increasing if the derivative is
positive that means that the function
was increasing as we approach that point
and then decreasing as we leave that
point which is a pretty good way to
think about this being a maximum point
if we're increasing as we approach it
and decreasing as we leave it then this
is definitely going to be
a maximum point
similarly right over here we see that
the function is negative or the
derivative is negative as we approach
the point which means that the function
is decreasing
and we see that derivative is positive
as we exit that point we go from having
a negative derivative to a positive
derivative which means the function goes
from decreasing to increasing right
around that point which is a pretty good
indication or that is the indication
that this critical point is a point at
which the function takes on a minimum
a minimum value
what i want to do now is extend things
by using the idea of concavity
concavity and i know i'm mispronouncing
it maybe it's concavity
but you thinking about
concavity we can start to look at the
second derivative rather than kind of
seeing just this transition to think
about whether this is a minimum or a
maximum point
so let's think about what's happening in
this first region this kind of this part
of the curve up here where it looks like
a arc where it's opening downward where
it looks kind of like an a without the
cross beam or an upside down u and then
we'll think about what's what's
happening in this kind of upward opening
u part of the curve
so over this first interval right over
here if we start over here the slope is
very
is very actually let me do it in a
actually i'll do that same color because
that's the same color i used for the
actual derivative the slope is very
positive slope is very positive then it
becomes less positive it becomes less
positive then it becomes even less
positive becomes even less positive it
eventually gets to zero eventually gets
to zero then it keeps decreasing now it
becomes slightly negative slightly
negative then it becomes even more
negative and then it stops decreasing
right around it looks like it stops
decreasing right around there so the
slope stops decreasing right on there
and you see that in the derivative the
slope is decreasing decreasing
decreasing decreasing until that point
and then it starts to increase so this
entire section this entire section right
over here this entire section right over
here the slope is decreasing
slope
is
decreasing
and you see it right over here when we
take the derivative the
the derivative right over here this
entire over this entire interval is
decreasing and we also see that when we
take the second derivative if the
derivative is decreasing that means that
the second derivative the derivative of
the derivative is negative and we see
that that that is indeed the case over
this entire interval the second
derivative the second derivative is
indeed negative
now what happens as we start to
transition to this upward opening u part
of the curve
well here the derivative is reasonably
negative it's reasonably negative right
there but then it starts gets it's still
negative but it becomes less negative
and less negative and less negative less
negative and less negative and less
negative then it becomes zero it becomes
zero right over here and then it becomes
more and more and more positive and you
see that right over here so over this
entire interval the slope or the
derivative is increasing
so the slope
slope is in
the slope is increasing and you see this
over here over here the slope is zero
the slope of the derivative is zero the
slope the derivative itself isn't
changing right at this moment and then
and then you see that the slope is
increasing and once again we can
visualize that on the second derivative
the derivative of the derivative if the
derivative is increasing that means the
derivative of that must be positive and
it is indeed the case
that the derivative is positive and we
have a word for these for this downward
opening u and this upward opening u we
call this concave downwards concave
downwards
downwards let me make this clear concave
downwards and we call this concave
upwards concave
upwards so let's review how we can
identify concave downward intervals and
concave upwards intervals so if we're
talking about concave downwards concave
downwards
we see several things we see that the
slope is decreasing
the slope
is
decreasing
the slope is decreasing which is another
way of saying which is another way of
saying that f prime
which is another way of saying that f
prime of x
is
decreasing is decreasing
decreasing which is another way of
saying that the second derivative must
be negative if the first derivative is
decreasing the second derivative the
second derivative must be negative which
is another way of saying that the second
derivative over that interval must be
must be negative so if you have a
negative second derivative then you are
in a concave downward interval
similarly similarly i have trouble
saying that word let's think about
concave upwards concave upwards where
you have an upward opening u
concave upwards
in these intervals the slope is
increasing we have a negative slope less
negative less negative zero positive
more positive more positive even more
positive so slope
slope is increasing
slope is
increasing which means
which means that the derivative
of the function is increasing
increasing
and you see that right over here this
derivative is increasing in value which
is which means that the second
derivative the second derivative over an
interval where we are concave upwards
must be greater than zero if the second
derivative is greater than zero that
means that the first derivative is
increasing which means that the slope is
increasing we are in an concave upward
we are in a concave upward interval
now given all of this these definitions
that we've just given for concave
downwards and concave upwards can we
come up with another way of identifying
whether a critical point is a minimum
point or a maximum point
well if you have a maximum point if you
have a critical point
where the function where the function is
concave downwards then you're going to
be at a maximum point concave downwards
let's just be clear here means that it's
opening
its opening down like this
and when we're talking about a critical
point if we're assuming it's concave
downwards over here we're assuming
differentiability over over this
interval and so the critical point is
going to be one where the slope is zero
so it's going to be that point right
over there so if you're concave
downwards and you have a point where f
prime
f prime of let's say a is equal to 0
then we have a maximum point at a we
have a maximum
point we have a maximum point at
at a
and similarly if we're concave upwards
that means that our function looks
something like this and if we found a
point obviously a critical point could
also be where the function is not
defined
but if we're assuming that our first
derivative and second derivative is
defined here then the critical point is
going to be one where the first
derivative is going to be zero
so f prime of a is equal to zero and if
we're cut if f prime of a is equal to
zero and if we're concave upwards or in
the interval around a so if the second
derivative is greater than zero then
it's pretty clear you see here that we
are dealing with
we are dealing with a minimum a minimum
point
at
a